les annonces de candidats se sont
multipliées dernièrement au québec mais
qu'est ce que ça prend exactement pour
se lance en politique c'est l'engagement
public la volonté de deux
de changer les choses implique de mettre
fin à une carrière pour en vendre une
autre de passer d'une vie privée et une
vie publique
c'est certainement vol salaires les
quatre partis 125 sièges à l'assemblée
nationale ça veut dire que les parties
doivent trouver au moins 600 candidats
si certains se propose deux mêmes les
parties doivent aussi convaincre de
potentielle candidature de prestige une
fois que cette réflexion l'aï fait mais
je vous dirais un sur dix chanceux 2 sur
10 accepte de se lancer dans l'aventuré
après viennent les vérifications si le
parti québécois québec solidaire pour
leur propre enquête interne
le parti libéral et la coalition avenir
québec recrute une firme pour analyser
le passé judiciaire financiers
professionnels des candidats il n'y a
pas de recherche parfaite à cet égard-là
la responsabilité elle appartient à la
candidate ou aux candidats c'est ici
qu'on en arrive aux médias sociaux
le parti québécois il ya goûté récemment
avec mme huguette payer et on change
parce qu'il ya une mine en arrière j'ai
fietz est spécialisée en vérification de
fait et fait des enquêtes sur le web on
est toujours responsable de son partant
sur les réseaux sociaux il ya des gens
qui ont dit et qu'on facebook depuis
plus d'une dizaine d'années est ce qu'on
se rappelle toujours de tout ce qu'on a
partagé sur les réseaux sociaux
il faut avoir des discrètes en plaquant
pour certaines personnes malheureusement
existe des outils pour pouvoir examiner
les données publiques une page facebook
et son regard de latence de black jack
stéphanie l'argent dans ces groupes
meilleur groupe en particulier que je
trouve intéressant c'est cette page que
neil young ancien groupe leur facebook
est géré par le coach aux actions
pardies qui est un groupe que certaines
personnes considèrent comme étant anti
immigration parfois ce sera un article
qu'un candidat partagé il ya plusieurs
années une vieille photo qui fait
sourciller un petit ménage dans son
passé que vous soyez candidat ou pas
peut parfois valoir la peine